let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not liberty
you [ __ ] eating [ __ ] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the tony
michaels podcast and this is tony
michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
[Music]
well good afternoon
happy hump day
thank you for joining us on let's talk
the tony michaels podcast
the tony michaels here
and we have a ton of news to get to
today and i know the common theme of
today's show
is going to be
hypocrisy
[Music]
because it seems to be the theme in the
country right now is hypocrisy hypocrisy
hypocrisy and there's a lot of hypocrisy
going around mainly on one one side but
there's a little bit there's a little
hypocrisy
on the other side as well
and we're gonna get to all this
hypocrisy hopefully today we only have
an hour but
maybe maybe
just maybe we'll be able to touch on all
the hypocrisy i doubt it i seriously
doubt it there's so much of it uh we
have we have christy gnome and corey
lewandowski in the news
we have matt gatz getting stuffed in a
trash can by mark milley uh just before
i came on i watched a clip of jim banks
defending nazis
you can't make this [ __ ] up you really
can't you got bill cosby
defending r kelly
we have we have uh the all or nothing
strategy from progressive democrats
uh so there's there's plenty of this
there's plenty of this to go around and
i'm sure
i'm sure today we'll get to a few parts
of it but
it just won't be as
as extensive as it can be in an hour
that's why i've been doing the live
twitch streams not every day but a lot
of days during the week and maybe we'll
start scheduling it where it's at a
certain time so you guys know when i'm
doing it because i just been doing it
whenever i get a chance and i start
surfing twitter and i just stream it
uh but go download the twitch app
or you can watch on twitter check out
the
the stream that i do where i i surf
twitter live because that's going to
give you a lot more commentaries on each
one of these topics because there's just
not enough time
in one hour of a week
to
to manage to fit in every single story
every single little nook and cranny of
commentary that we have uh so we don't
do the podcast every day maybe we should
but i do this live stream
surfing twitter thing whatever it is on
twitch it's also streams on twitter so
if you if you want to download the
twitch app you can find it there the
tonymichaels go check that out or check
it out on twitter a lot of people have
been watching it over there i don't know
if i'm doing it right or not i'm not
sure what
live streaming was exactly i thought
twitch was a gaming thing but it's it's
more than just gaming it's more than
just gaming so i've been streaming over
there so you guys can listen to me rant
and rave about every little topic that
comes up on twitter
but we have a lot to talk about today
this week on
let's talk the tony michaels podcast
again
we do this show every week on wednesdays
three o'clock central four o'clock
eastern uh last couple weeks we've had a
special guest episode we're not gonna
have a special guest episode this week
but it looks like we will next week
next week it looks like we're gonna have
a special guest episode on friday as you
guys know if you've been listening uh we
have guests on and i pre-record them and
then air them on fridays at three
o'clock central four o'clock eastern so
the same exact time we did a live show
we just do it on friday and i stream it
live but it is recorded and it looks
like next week we're going to have a
guest
we're working on getting that guest so
we'll announce that next week as it
comes along and we get our recording
done
for that show but this week we don't
have a special guest episode but it
looks like next week we will so i'll be
announcing that so tune in next week to
the live show at wednesday three o'clock
central four o'clock eastern and also if
we do end up having that guest episode
next week or the week after but i think
it's gonna happen next week
tune in to that as well so be aware that
next week we have a special special
guest episode this week we do not
so let's get into the topics of today
and again the overall theme is hypocrisy
and it always seems to be with some of
these [ __ ] uh the first story with bill
cosby and r kelly i don't even know that
that i have to even go through this much
i mean it's not surprising that a [ __ ]
box defends another [ __ ] box of course a
[ __ ] rapist is gonna defend a [ __ ]
rapist
do i need to say any more than that and
do we need to pay attention to what the
[ __ ] bill cosby thinks about rapists
other than that that that that's
probably we can lay that to bed that's
enough commentary at that point because
[ __ ] our kelly and [ __ ] bill cosby and
[ __ ] anyone who did anything like what
they did [ __ ] them there you go there's
my commentary on bill cosby
now we also have the hypocrisy of corey
lewandowski and christy gnome
this week we've got a lot of south
dakota christie gnome
news apparently her daughter was trying
to apply for a real estate appraisal
license they turned her down
probably for good reason i don't know
why and they just turned her down
i mean you know there's probably
decent hurdles that you have to get over
to act like you know what you're doing
when you're appraising real estate in a
s in you know when it's licensed by the
state
but apparently she was denied this
license christy gnome did not like that
so she used her authority to bully the
board that uh appoints this
license to people who appraise real
estate in south dakota
and also it seems like uh after it after
she bullied them and pressured them they
gave her daughter her license
and the person who was in charge of that
got fired um so they have that scandal
going on
and i i don't know if it appears that
there's any crimes being committed
other than you know spending your
political capital for your daughter to
get her appraisals like appraiser's
license when she could have just
reapplied i'm assuming
but you're spending your political
capital there but we find out also and
this may be a cover story for it or not
i don't know who knows who knows with
these [ __ ] i mean we had the [ __ ]
grabber and chief
win a presidency after everyone heard
him on tape say he grabs women by the
[ __ ]
so who knows who knows maybe this is a
strategy to cover up the actual story of
her bullying the board to give her
daughter the appraiser's license and
maybe a payment was taking place i don't
know some people are saying that it's
not very unclear what's happening with
that story at this point maybe that's
why this other story gets leaked
about her schlubbing corey lewandowski
which is the former trump campaign
manager you know who corey lewandowski
is at [ __ ] shitbox i mean it really
isn't surprising that someone like corey
lewandowski
is running around taking advantage of
women in the trump orbit i mean he he
supposedly with hope hicks and some
others he's accused of
physical assault with women it's not
surprising that this guy is a home
wrecker
if that's the case
and it's not surprising that christy
gnome who runs around
riding on horses with american flags and
cowboy hats on talking about a american
christian values
is having an extra marital affair
with with the trump campaign manager
not surprising at all that that level of
hypocrisy
exists in christie gnome and and the the
problem is here for christy nomins she's
trying to be
either a presidential candidate for 2024
or the vice pres the vice presidential
pick for grandpa poopypants
and if that's what she's going for that
might work i mean because these q anon
maga pedophile defending
uh extramarital affair [ __ ] grabbing
defending people out there to vote for
trump these trump bumpers these
evangelicals these hypocritical
evangelicals they're more likely to
probably vote for christie gnome
if she has some of this you know
salacious stuff
in her story
where she's having an affair with corey
lewandowski the former campaign manager
which will probably be the campaign
manager for trump in 2024 if he gets
criminally indicted and decides to stave
off a criminal indictment by running for
president that's right i said it that's
why he's going to run if he runs is to
stave off any kind of federal criminal
indictment because he's going to believe
that oh well if i'm running for
president they can't touch me that
that's that's what's going to happen
that's the only reason to run that's the
only reason to be president in the first
place that's the only reason to
attempt a cheeto dust kangaroo coup
that's the only reason is to remain
president so you're not indicted
i mean that's the fear here of these
[ __ ]
now speaking of hypocrisy i want to
touch on something here that is very
important but before i do that i want to
tell you what we're going to do after i
have the discussion about unity
unity
a lot of people are disgruntled out
there in this country of who they voted
for who they didn't vote for or whatever
i'm gonna try to lay that to bed today
i'm gonna try to get a message out there
so if you're watching this on twitter or
if you're watching this and go share
this son of a [ __ ] because i'm about to
lay it all out but before i do i want to
tell you what we're going to do after
the unity conversation
because i want you to stay tuned here
because i am going to show the entire
[ __ ] matt gats clip from earlier and
i'm gonna rip him to [ __ ] shreds
every single piece of that [ __ ] clip
we are gonna tear apart
because i watched it several times today
and number one i don't know why the [ __ ]
he's questioning anybody but we're going
to get to that so i want to let you know
that we're going to watch that clip and
i'm going to tear him the [ __ ] apart and
i'll probably get to jim banks too
because i don't have that clip
handy
but i watched it and uh i want to
comment on it and maybe maybe we'll
watch it tomorrow on the the live stream
and i'll tear them apart again because
oh boy well am i going to enjoy tearing
in the gym banks here it's going to be
really fun so stay tuned to that but
let's get back to unity here because
there is a little hypocrisy on the
democratic side here
and a lot of people i i've even gotten
uh private messages saying they're just
you know oh the democratic party's
really disappointing me
and what's going on here why why can't
we get this done and why can't we well
here's the thing here's the thing
is uh
we we need to make sure that we unify
against fascism here this is not this is
not a a thing where we act we get to
pick and choose
exact details on every single piece of
legislation on every single piece of
societal measures here
we do not get to pick and choose there's
only one choice that we have and that is
to still continue the fight to defeat
fascism in this country and it is
disguised as trumpism
right now in this country we have
fascism wearing a maga hat trumpism
and it's continuing and they're really
pushing it i mean good god they're
they're selling the [ __ ] out of out of
fascism in this country
you have uh
sydney powell linwood uh mike lindell
and and mike flynn running around the
country basically promoting a cheeto
dust confederacy
mike flynn even saying as much as we
basically saying we need to overturn the
constitution of the united states
because it doesn't work for us anymore
we need to have a confederacy that is
what he is saying
in a clip
where he's at this conference at the
ccpd or some stupid [ __ ] i don't know
what the [ __ ] it is some kind of nazi
group
these are [ __ ] nazis they're [ __ ]
confederates they're [ __ ] fascist
okay they're disguised as trumpist with
their [ __ ] maga hats but it's fascism
they want to overthrow the united states
of america they tried it on january 6
with the cheeto dust kangaroo coup and
now they want the cheeto dust kangaroo
confederacy
that's what they want
because they don't like the others
that's fascism
and the others are liberals jesus christ
they're running commercials on newsmax
and oan basically saying that that if
you have the liberal ideology you are an
enemy of the state
which is
[ __ ] insanity because there's no
liberal running around saying we need to
overthrow the constitution of the united
states
or that we need to king joe biden or the
crown joe biden king and make him the
dictator not [ __ ] one it's actually
the opposite
it's actually the opposite with this
unity thing
because there's progressives that are
trying to stall joe biden's agenda here
which right wrong or indifferent they
have the right they have the right as an
elected official to make their to make
to make their
their opinions known
they have the right to stake what they
say they were gonna do but look the
american people elected democrats
specifically joe biden not because they
love joe biden
not because they love you progressives
not because they love democrats
it's because of neo-liberalism and if
you are so [ __ ] if you are so [ __ ]
out of touch with self-awareness that
you do not realize that neoliberalism is
what delivered us joe biden as opposed
to trump because 81 million people did
not vote for joe biden
that's right i said it
81 million people did not vote for joe
biden they voted against trump
they voted against fascism
do you understand that
so the progressives out there better get
off their [ __ ] high horse and they
better get off it soon
and the reason why is because they have
to deliver for the american people what
they said they were going to deliver
because it's not just progressives out
there that are waiting for these things
to happen it's not just progressives out
there waiting for this infrastructure
bill waiting for a voting rights package
it's not just [ __ ] progressives
we have moderates we have anti-trumpers
we have trumpers who are going to love
they are going to love this
infrastructure package when it passes
they're going to act like they don't
like it but believe you me believe you
me when this thing passes you'll have
all these republicans
going all over the country during their
2022 race talking about how they
delivered infrastructure
they're going to
mark my words
because it's popular
that's why you don't see any of them out
there
railing against the child tax credit
you don't have em going oh my god that
child tax credit's awful and we need to
get rid of that thing we need to not put
money in your account every month to
help you raise your children
nope not one not [ __ ] one of them not
one of them
they'll say things like oh socialism bad
this infrastructure builds socialism
socialism socialism radical commies
they'll stay stuff like that
and they're not just talking they're not
just talking about the progressives that
are the ones holding this bill in the
house
now i have high confidence
high confidence folks
that there this is going to cave just
like mitch mcconnell and the republicans
are going to cave on the debt ceiling
will the government shut down i don't
know
what shutdown vermont in the week really
[ __ ] unlikely
really [ __ ] unlikely here's the
reason why
is because the people who have the
interest of the government staying open
are going to go to mitch mcconnell and
the republicans and say hey
hey
we had fun and all we had fun and all
with your little game with the debt
ceiling and not paying off the debt but
uh you're stopping our payments
you need to turn the faucet back on and
i'm talking about the one percent
yeah yeah they're going to be a little
pissed off when the government shuts
down and they're not making the money
they want to make
it's going to happen
and the republicans are going to get
blamed for this there's 81 million
people that are on to the republicans
here progressives who aren't doing
infrastructure in the house because they
want to one bill to pass before the
other get the [ __ ] out of here
get the [ __ ] out of here
with your with your [ __ ]
your your show politics
this country did not want that kind of
politics
let me let me rewind the clock a little
bit remind you of what happened in in in
2020
with the democratic primary in this
country
are you ready are you ready people out
there who want to know the [ __ ] truth
who want it straight
everyone thought joe biden was done
bernie sanders was going to win
california bernie sanders is going to
win texas it was over until they got to
south carolina
and joe biden slam dunk south carolina
and then slam dunk state after state
after state after state and it ain't
because joe biden's some kind of special
human being
that's not why it's because what joe
biden was saying
and the message that joe biden had
versus the message that bernie sanders
had bernie sanders had an all or nothing
message it's all or nothing
and the american people like no no
no all or nothing's not good enough
all or nothing is not good enough we
want something it's been a long
[ __ ] time since we had [ __ ]
done in this country and we want [ __ ]
done and so far
so far progressive democrats who want to
try to stall this thing
and spend your political capital to
stall this thing by the way the
president that the people elected in the
primary the candidate joe biden that
they elected to do something not nothing
the candidate they elected has done a
lot
and done a lot of [ __ ] that he said he
was gonna do already
so if you think you're gonna hold up
this infrastructure and this
reconciliation package
against 81 million people who voted for
the guy who said he's gonna get [ __ ]
done has been getting [ __ ] done
good luck
good luck to you i wish you well
in your political career
because your constituents may think
that's great but the american people are
not just like the american people are
not going to put up with joe manchin and
chris and cinema hanging onto this
filibuster much longer for voting rights
or for anything else for that matter
hell two months ago three months ago
most the people in this country would
have settled for some some sort of
compromise on the filibuster to be a
standing filibuster the way that it used
to be in the way it was intended to be
not anymore they want that [ __ ]
dead
you're only pushing the argument on the
other side so democrats rather your joe
manchin and chris and cinema holding up
what the american people want because of
your stupid [ __ ] idea that the
filibuster has to live
we gotta have the filibuster to have
democracy even though the filibuster may
kill democracy oh it makes a lot of
[ __ ] sense
the american people are not gonna put up
with that [ __ ] they're not there's going
to be an election here soon and you're
going to see it i think you're going to
see it in virginia i think you already
saw it in california recall
three to one vote
the same way progressive democrats in
the house
if you don't if you if you if you accept
nothing all or nothing
burn it all down all or nothing strategy
in the house with these infrastructure
bills which i don't think they're going
to do
there's one thing that nancy pelosi is
good at and
absolutely destroying
destroying republicans she's the gq
kiritmanite
100 full stop they can't manage her
but there's another thing that can't be
that they can't manage nancy pelosi
either
and that's progressives in the house i
believe she will whip these people into
shape the same way that the the richest
one percent will whip mitch mcconnell
into shape and get this debt ceiling
raised
i have full confidence now
what price us american people pay in the
in the process is the question and
that's where you're gonna pay that's
where you're gonna pay you're gonna pay
political capital by making the american
people wait for you guys to have
theatrics
so you can continue to have your
theatrics and just piss the [ __ ]
voting block
off you can do that if you want or you
can just admit that you were wrong
just admit you're wrong hey the american
people want this and it's better to have
something than nothing this all or
nothing strategy is not going to work
just come out and just admit it it's
fine we won't hold it against you and
you know what joe manchin and chris and
cinema if you guys come out today and
say hey
that filibuster thing i was just
bullshitting let's get rid of that thing
done
done we're good we're good from here on
out
this is not that difficult it really
isn't it really isn't to get political
capital in this country right now
this this country is not divided it's
united against fascism it's united
against trumpism
they want to overthrow the constitution
of the united states
that's what they want
that's what trump wants that's what
that's what the [ __ ] trump pumpers
want that's what the gqp wants because
they know
they know if they don't undermine the
constitution they won't have
power because the majority of the
country isn't buying what they're
selling anymore and they [ __ ] tied
themselves to what they're selling when
they nominated trump to be the [ __ ]
candidate of their party i mean even
[ __ ]
lady g lindsey graham said it
if he becomes our nominee it will
destroy our party
now i mean
he said that back then and he knows that
now but he's not admitting it
just like mitch mcconnell won't admit
that yeah we're gonna have to raise the
debt ceiling
that is something we're gonna have to do
if we want to keep getting money from
our donors that is something we're gonna
have to do
his donors are not gonna let him destroy
the credibility
and the credit
of the united states of america they're
not going to let that happen
and he will be blamed for because he
will cave
the same way progressive democrats in
the house
will cave on this bill
they're gonna cave somewhere something's
gotta give
you cannot do an all or nothing policy
it it's not a thing that you can do
anymore we voted against that
we the country
we nominated a nominee that was the
opposite of that
the other nominee was selling all or
nothing
all or nothing all or nothing all or
nothing
and it got voted against it was not a
thing that happened we voted for the
candidate that was the opposite of all
or nothing and then when it came to the
general election we voted for the
anti-fascist candidate
so you could say there's unity in this
country and there's a lot of it to go
around
there's a hell of a lot of it to go
around
it just is not with fascist
it's not with fascists so mitch
mcconnell my suggestion is and chris and
cinema and joe manchin my suggestion is
if you want to survive
politically you might want to be on the
opposite side of fascism
oh and by the way progressive democrats
in the house
with the infrastructure bill to deliver
infrastructure to the american people
because let's let's remind them what's
at stake here this isn't this isn't like
some kind of show thing where they're
naming a post office
we're talking about over five trillion
dollars of money that is going to funnel
down into the american people into the
communities red states blue states
metropolitan areas rural areas five
trillion dollars is going to funnel down
in infrastructure and i'm not just
talking about roads and bridges
we're talking about healthcare
internet
education
there's a ton of infrastructure money
that's going to dump into communities
all around this country and it's going
to lift up the american people
got it
we haven't had a real infrastructure
bill in a long time a real one a [ __ ]
real one a real investment in the
american infrastructure
and by the american infrastructure i
mean the american people
and if you progressive democrats are
gonna say well it's not worth it
let fascism have it let the republicans
have a win let that bill die and let the
republicans win because let me tell you
something let me tell you something
a loss on this bill and a loss on the
work on the infrastructure package and
the reconciliation bill that's already
been done by people in the senate and in
the house democrats only because
republicans aren't there to help
they don't give a [ __ ] about the
american people why would they have
anything to do with this bill
you're with them you're with them
that's that's the side you're on when
you're against this bill because i'm
gonna vote on one before the other
or oh it's got little things in it and i
want this thing in it i don't want that
thing in it
get the [ __ ] out of here quit being
little children
and do the thing that you got elected to
do which is go get infrastructure and go
get real [ __ ] policy for the american
people enough of this all or nothing
politics
[ __ ]
we are not a divided country folks
i believe i believe that we are united
against fascism and united against this
[ __ ] [ __ ] where we it's all or
nothing it's all or nothing we're united
against that [ __ ]
that's what i believe i think that's the
truth
ah man he may disagree with me i don't
give a [ __ ] you think the guy who has
[ __ ] him on his hat gives a [ __ ]
no
we should be intolerant of the
intolerant
and we should unite where we can unite
and say [ __ ] them to the ones who won't
[ __ ] them
[ __ ] them
you don't want to unite for the american
people and get deliver them the things
that they want need
like that like you did with the
coronavirus package you did it with
coronavirus you did it you did it when
you supported joe biden to get out of
the afghanistan war
you did it
you've done it
over and over again just in this [ __ ]
nine months
it's time to do it again
it's time to do it again it's time to
unite forces republicans to make a vote
again
and again and again and again on the
debt ceiling and until they cave
it'll be blamed on them because they'll
be the ones who cave
they're the ones who voted against the
united states paying their bills that
they already [ __ ]
ran up the credit card debt for
to give tax breaks to the rich
are you listening progressive democrats
you're on their side when you're saying
no to this bill that's what you're doing
you're on their side you're giving them
a win if we are going to win and we're
going to take power we have to win we
have to win
at every stake every moment every spot
everywhere we can we have to win and by
we i mean the american people
we have to win against the fascist
they want
they want
to tear down
our democracy
are you listening are you paying
attention
they want to tear down our democracy
and the best way the best way is to
deliver to the american people what the
american people voted for
and they will continue to vote for that
thing
81 million
81 million
do you hear me
i think this is going to be the biggest
turnout in the midterm
in in
gonna be a record
it's gonna be a record
so where do you want those votes to lie
where
where do you want those votes to lie
progressive democrats
huh the all or nothing strategy
is that what you want
to suppress your own vote or do you want
them to suppress their vote because
they're they're breeding in confidence
in the vote
they have a strategy of no no no nothing
no policy
they they voted
they voted for the american economy to
crash
janet yelling is saying by october 18th
this thing's gonna get real real [ __ ]
fast and quick and in a hurry
and i would imagine by october 18th
mitch mcconnell gets his [ __ ] together
here
they always get blamed for shutting down
the government it's because they're the
ones who shut it down
how how in the [ __ ] how the [ __ ] do they
think they're gonna sell this all
democrats shut down the they love the
government so much
then big government democrats loves
government so much that they shut it
down get the [ __ ] out of here
get the [ __ ] out of here and how are you
gonna sell progressive democrats that
you did nothing
huh
we didn't do anything because
all or nothing how is that going to sell
think about it
you're going to have the biggest vote
voting block in the history of a midterm
and you're going to sell nothing 100 or
nothing it's all or nothing we don't
want you to have anything if we can't
get exactly what we want
well that ain't how it works
that's not how a republic works that's
not how a democracy works that's not how
compromise works that's that's not how
it works and the reason why their side
is freaking out so much the reason why
white privilege is right
running rampant around this country is
because they don't understand that you
don't get what you want you don't get to
do whatever the [ __ ] you want to do
that's not how it works that is not you
have consequences of your choices
your choices have consequences
that's how it works
and sometimes you have to make choices
you don't want to make and sometimes
the choice you make isn't always the
best
but it's the best in the moment the best
you can do at the time
just like right now they can't get
children from age 5 to 11 vaccinated yet
so the best choice they have is to make
them wear masks in school so they don't
get sick
to mitigate that risk it's not the
greatest choice but it's the choice you
have to make
that's what you have to do
well if we can't if we can't
have them just safe to no school at all
all or nothing get the [ __ ] out of here
no no human being
runs through life doing an all or
nothing strategy on anything their job
their family their work their mortgage
all or nothing doesn't work that's what
they're doing
their message is we're going to sell
nothing we're going to do everything
against everything we're against
everything we're against everything so
get on board
get on board with them
get on board
because the american people are going to
make you pay
so you better find 10 [ __ ] votes i
think it's about 10 i think nancy pelosi
will find him i have
the utmost confidence i'm not always a
nancy pelosi fan
but there's one thing good about nancy
pelosi she knows how to get [ __ ] done
you you can't you cannot say that she
does not know how to get [ __ ] done she
definitely knows how to move the ball
forward
and i i have confidence that she's going
to whip these members into shape here
whip them into shape and make them
realize that
it's not only good for the country but
it's good for you politically
because the people who voted for joe
biden the 81 million people who voted
for joe biden kamala harris to get
infrastructure done there they want
infrastructure done they want that done
they that 81 million people want that
done
maybe that's a good way to sell it i
don't know
all right let's get to the mat gats
clip because
[Laughter]
oh
this is
oh this was bound bound to be a great
theater here uh when you're talking
about a committee hearing when mark
milley and secretary austin show up
to uh
to defend themselves for the afghanistan
decision
and uh matt gatz and even jim banks i
seen a clip of him turning themselves
into circles and
and tying themselves in the knots and
pretzels here with hypocrisy is
absolutely a guess so i i made the
decision today i was just gonna play the
little clip where mark millen just
absolutely slam dunks on matt gatz but
i said you know what i actually want to
take the entire questioning and break
this apart of how this number one why
this [ __ ] even can question
someone in the committee how in the [ __ ]
is it that someone under under federal
criminal
investigation for for sex trafficking
which his co-conspirator in the case has
already pled guilty to is even allowed
to question anyone on anything
at the bare minimum the bare minimum
this he should be suspended from his
committee assignments until an ethics
investigation is done in the in congress
bear [ __ ] minimum
he actually should be expelled and and
probably arrested and prosecuted i'm not
sure why we haven't got to that point
yet it appears to me that matt gatz is
actually turning state's evidence on
somebody here
that's right if if matt gatz has
evidence on you out there it appears to
me the evidence would suggest that it it
looks like to me that he's turning
evidence on somebody
so if you if you if you're higher up the
chain than matt gatz in this joel
greenberg case you might you might want
to make that consideration
you just might i don't know
i'm no expert and i don't know anything
but i do it does seem to appear
that he's turning evidence on somebody
otherwise if the if the joel greenberg
case is credible
he would probably already be under
federal indictment
i can't even imagine how many proffers
that matt gatz may have done already
now
why he's questioning someone he should
be expelled from congress but at a bare
minimum he should not be questioning
anyone on anything in any committee
hearing just like [ __ ] marjorie
taylor green who interview it was
interviewed by cat turd i'm not [ __ ]
you marjorie taylor green hoof foot
green
was [ __ ] interviewed by cat turd
this is a real thing
this i'm i'm not [ __ ] you
you think it's [ __ ] i margie taylor
green was interviewed by cat turd
[ __ ] and you think i'm crazy having the
word [ __ ] them on my stuff
interviewed by cat turd maybe i could
get maybe i can get some candidates on
my show
holy actual [ __ ]
but we have matt get she's she can't
even be in a committee she's not even in
committee but we have matt gatt's
mr venmo receipt
who allegedly has
definitely allegedly
broken federal laws sex trafficking laws
but i would say that uh committing sex
trafficking laws if those allegations
are true they would be against
congressional ethics and you might want
to suspend that person from being able
to ask anything to anybody on any
committee anywhere
i mean he shouldn't even be questioning
the dog catcher about how they pick up
dog turds in the pound
okay
now i'm gonna play this entire clip and
it is a long clip i think it's like five
minutes here
but once we're done i'm gonna i'm gonna
break down every single part of this
because i've watched it probably five
times
i i want to tear matt gatz apart and
dump him in a [ __ ] trash can here
because that is the thing that he
deserves
and i know what they're gonna do
in conservative they're gonna on newsmax
and oan and fox news and all these
these [ __ ] shills for trump these
as jim banks calls them these nazi
organizations because that's what they
are jim banks admitted it you call them
nazis and how dare you say what they are
how dare you i'll get to that
we're gonna play this whole matt gats
clip
and i'm going i'm going to
to break it down afterwards so let's
just go ahead and play the [ __ ] clip
february 26 2020 house armed services
committee general mark milley
we know we're not going to defeat the
taliban militarily and they're not going
to defeat the government of afghanistan
militarily
you really blew that call didn't you
general
i believe that that was a
issue of strategic stalemate and that if
we had remained in afghanistan
uh with the advisory levels of effort
than the government of afghanistan
that's an interesting answer to a
question it's just not one i asked you
spent more time with bob woodward on
this book than you spent analyzing the
very likely prospect that the
afghanistan government was going to fall
immediately to the taliban didn't you
not even close congressman oh really
because you said right after kabul fell
that no one could have anticipated the
immediate fall of the ghani government
when did you become aware that joe biden
tried to get ghani to lie about the
conditions in afghanistan he did that in
july did you know that right away
i'm not aware of what president biden
you're not aware of the phone call that
biden had with ghani where he said
whether it is true or not we want you to
go out there and paint a rosy picture of
what's going on in afghanistan you're
the chief military adviser to the
president you said that the taliban was
not going to defeat the government of
afghanistan militarily which by the way
they cut through them like a hot knife
through butter and then the president
tries to get ghani to lie when did you
become aware of that attempt well
there's two things there congressman if
i may one
is what i said was the situation with
stalemate and if we kept advisors with
there the government of afghanistan and
the army would have still been there
that's what i said whether that's right
or wrong i don't know but seems wrong
now well
secretary austin
are you capable of assessing whether
another has the will to fight
no we're not and that's the point that
the chairman made earlier
that's just like an incredibly
disappointing thing for the secretary of
defense to simply say i can't assess
whether someone has the will to fight
but it is consistent with your record i
mean during the obama administration i
think they gave you about 48 million
dollars to go train up some folks in
syria to go take on the assad government
and i think your testimony was that only
four or five survived first contact with
the enemy so what confidence should this
committee have in you or should the
country have in you when you've now
confessed to us and whether it's the
swing and a miss in afghanistan that
general milly talked to the senate about
yesterday
total failure or whether it was your
failures in syria you don't seem capable
to look at a fighting force and
determine whether or not they have the
will is that an embarrassment
congressman that uh the end result was
uh uh
uh the sdf that we stood up that was
very very instrumental in turning the
tide of uh
a battle up in syria oh yeah
turned it so much you've got assad in
power in syria you got the taliban in
power in afghanistan i mean where have
you been the focus was the focus was
isis congressman
and we and those forces uh had
significant uh effect on the isis
network it just seems like you're
chronically bad at this and you have
admitted that i guess which is
to your credit but you know when
when people in the military like
lieutenant colonel stewart sheller stand
up and demand accountability when they
say that you all screwed up when they
point out that general milly's statement
that the talent you know that the
government of afghanistan is not going
to get defeated by the taliban well he
ends up in the brig
and you all end up in front of us and
your former employer raytheon ends up
with a lot of money and we have poured
cash and blood and credibility into a
ghani government that was a mirage it
fell immediately and while the guy
sitting next to you was off you know
talking to phil rucker and was off doing
his thing with bob woodward
we were buying into the big lie the big
lie that this that this was ever going
to be successful that we could ever rely
on the afghanistan government for
anything at all you know general mill
you kind of gave up the game earlier
when you said you wanted to address
elements of your personal conduct that
were in question we're not questioning
your personal conduct we're questioning
in your official capacity going and
undermining the chain of command which
is obviously what you did you've created
this whole chain not undermined
yeah you did you absolutely did and not
well you know what
you said yesterday that you weren't
going to resign when senators asked you
this question
and i believe that you guys probably
won't resign you seem to be
very happy failing up over there
but if we didn't have a president that
was so addled
you all would be fired because that is
what you deserve you have let down the
people who wear the uniform in my
district and all around this country and
you're far more interested in what your
perception is and how people think about
you and insider washington books than
you care about winning
this group is incapable of doing
a miss wilhelm is recognized
okay
so mr venmo there
captain [ __ ] and it's very apparent
from he just is questioning that he has
been on the phone with grandpa
poopypants for the last
how god knows how many days trying to
figure out exactly all the questions
that he was going to ask mark milley
and the questions that that the cheeto
dust mobster wanted to make sure that
those punches he got on mark millie
which obviously did not work not [ __ ]
one of them because they're all they're
all bred in hypocrisy absolutely all of
it i just find it kind of funny that he
bought a copy of the book
and keeps holding
he bought he purchased
he's so mad about the book
that he bought a copy and he's
advertised
he's advertising the book for bob
woodward and bob acosta he keeps holding
up the book like this book here
advertisement
product placement like he never even
says that the book's a lie like he's
admitting that the book is true
to some degrees he's actually kind of
given it some credibility by holding it
up and be like yes this book here you
did all these credible interviews with
this book and what you said in this
book i find it kind of funny that he
went out and purchased a copy of the
book
to hold he couldn't just say in the book
in the book peril
i mean he couldn't just say it you could
have just said it you didn't have to buy
the book and support the book
but
let's start with the book first then
because he keeps going on and on and on
about spending time with bob woodward on
this book
and how oh that's so egregious that you
weren't doing your job and you were
spending time with bob woodward on this
book peril and oh my god how egregious
what what could possibly good come of
that like if a president of the united
states spent time and time and time on a
phone interview with bob woodward about
a book you know during a pandemic like
in january march in in april of of 2020
when he was being interviewed by bob
woodward over and over and over again
for a book like trump did what the [ __ ]
are you talking about
what the [ __ ] are you and then you're
totally [ __ ] ignoring how much golf
grandpa poopypants played
during his presidency so mark milley is
supposed to do his job 24 7
every single day not one interview that
he can give he is the chairman of the
joint chiefs
his [ __ ] job is to advise the
president united states
that's his [ __ ] job
and he was doing his [ __ ] job
and by the way
what i would like to ask matt gatz and
i'm sure federal authorities would like
to ask maguettes is where were you doing
your job when you were trafficking
underage women across state lines and
paying them on venmo on your venmo
account where were you doing your job at
that point or was that part of your job
i'm i'm really i'm trying to figure that
out
but he goes to austin and you notice
austin
he he he tries to question austin and
austin
stuffs him in a locker
within a matter of two questions because
he rambles on and on and on about the
taliban and afghanistan and how he
failed and they failed in syria with the
taliban
and austin's like no no that was isis
that was isis that had nothing new
that had nothing to do with afghanistan
or talib that was isis it was a totally
different group of people i don't know
if you're aware but they're they're two
different two different organizations
and oh by the way
speaking of the taliban he totally
forgets
he totally [ __ ] he totally matt gas
totally forgets that it was grandpa
poopy pants it was the cheeto dust
mobster that made the deal with the
taliban for the taliban to take back
afghanistan
it was his mango mussolini jesus his
orange deity that did that deal
that was the whole point
that was that was why we had to get out
by september 1st in the first place
that's what they were saying yesterday
in the senate when mark milley was
saying when the the generals
in general were saying hey
it wasn't perfect but if we left troops
in afghanistan it would have been a
[ __ ] fire fight and we would have had
to surge more troops back in to help
with a firefight it would have been a
battle the taliban had already made the
deal with trump to take afghanistan
and they were already on the move to do
that it was obvious that afghanistan was
a house of cards to begin with and the
deal that trump made made it even more
of a house of cards and made it crash
even faster
but that's the reality that we had to
live in
and i do find it also kind of funny how
matt gatz at the very end you see
matt getz accuse
mark milly
and i you know
rather you agree with it or not
accuse him of skipping the chain of
command because the the the the
allegation there is that mark milly
skipped the chain in command for trump
you guys all heard this story where mark
milley had to contact his counterpart in
china he had meetings with nancy pelosi
he had meetings with a dod
about a nuclear weapon being used
and he reassures the committee today and
he did it yesterday too that he did not
believe that that donald trump was going
to use any kind of nuclear force or any
kind of force for that matter on a
foreign entity
rather it be iran or china or whoever
to create this situation where
somehow he could declare himself the
dictator because he was throwing bombs
at someone or some [ __ ]
now that idea came from somewhere and it
probably came out of the mouths of
people like mike flynn sydney powell
rudy giuliani and they were sitting in
front of him saying this stuff and
people were getting [ __ ] alarmed that
someone was whispering this into [ __ ]
the cheeto dust mobster's ear
i mean he takes a lot of stupid [ __ ] a
lot of delusional [ __ ] seriously so yeah
it seemed like they were probably
[ __ ] concerned
that these conversations were even
happening within a hundred miles of the
president of the united states
and never in the modern history have we
had to have the chairman of the joint
chiefs be terrified so terrified that
that a maniac that holds the president
the office of the president of the
united states that maniac would do
almost anything almost anything to
retain power
that he had to call his counterpart in
china and say no no no no we have
protocols that's not how it works he
can't just bomb you
because that's what he did he was saying
hey that's not how it works that there's
legal things that happen before a
present united states can just launch a
nuclear weapon somewhere to remain
dictator there's like a legal process
there's procedures that happen and he
was reminding people who carry out those
procedures remember
bone up on your procedures because you
may need them
and he was reassuring china that hey
i've already reassured everyone of the
legal procedures that happen and there's
no chance that this guy is gonna
launch a nuclear attack to stay in power
but the fact the fact that he had to do
all that only tells you that
somewhere somewhere there was a
conversation within earshot of that
[ __ ] maniac now rather he took it
seriously or not that's beyond the point
that that they were allowing those
conversations to be with an earshot of
that [ __ ] idiot
now
matt gatz is totally upset that mark
millie may have jumped over chain of
command for trump which is not true
it's not true
jumped over chain of command with trump
but matt gatz also at the same time he
wants him to jump the chain of command
for biden
do you notice that how he he's so pissed
off that mark milly couldn't [ __ ]
jump command for why didn't you save now
why didn't you jump command with biden
why didn't you
and then all at the same time he's mad
he's mad that he jumped chain of command
for trump which both things are not true
neither one of them are true and he's
mad about two opposite things that are
not true do you know why i said the
[ __ ] theme of today was hypocrisy
because matt gatz pops up in the [ __ ]
news
he's [ __ ] idiot
the other thing that i think meant gets
and i call him matt gats
yeah it's not gates it's not spelled
gates it's spelled gets
and i would imagine that it [ __ ]
pisses him off when someone says his
name wrong gets
so as long as he thinks it's gates i'm
going with gets
[ __ ] them
so man little mister maddie gets
little mr
maddie getz
doesn't also realize because he wants
he's to uh if you if you were if you
were had a real president you'd be fired
well there was a president that didn't
fire him
trump didn't fire him so are you saying
that trump's an adult
a human being that he's a
such a
[ __ ] loaf that he couldn't fire mark
milly when he jumped chain of command
because that's what you're saying about
biden
he really can't decide that if the
military that trump had is that the same
military that that biden has because it
is
the military that biden has is the same
[ __ ] military that trump had it's the
exact same one
how how the [ __ ] can't we how the [ __ ]
can't this reality
come to light that that we have to
actually explain this to people how in
the [ __ ] is this even a thing that you
have to explain to people that when a
president becomes the president he
doesn't just
send off all the military and then
collect all new military personnel it's
the same [ __ ] military
it's the same military essentially that
obama had at the end of his presidency
i mean the military changes over a
four-year period in over administration
but essentially it's kind of the same
military i mean it's not the same
military as george w bush had because
that was that was many years ago so it's
changed over the years but it's
essentially the exact same military that
trump had the exact same it's very
similar to the military that obama had
very similar
how the [ __ ] doesn't anyone know this
this is united states military
how the [ __ ] do you not know that it is
the same exact military
and matt gatz totally misses that he's
talking about a president who can't tell
you know right right from wrong or nine
from ten or two from one
sleepy joe biden as they call him
they can't understand that if if joe
biden
was derelict in his duty for not firing
mark milley
for jumping the chain of command well
it's obvious that the grandpa poopy
pants the cheeto dust mobster thinks he
jumped the chain of command you're
asking him the question from mar-a-lago
well from new jersey right now because
he's he's kicked out on his ass in
mar-a-lago he's got to be a transient
for a while
this is where we're at we're we're at a
failed the failed blogger transient
feeding questions to the goddamn sex
trafficker
who can still ask questions to a goddamn
general
unserious people
asking unserious questions in a serious
[ __ ] hearing about a serious [ __ ]
issue like afghanistan where 13 service
members gave their [ __ ] lives to
protect americans and afghanistan
refugees where they made [ __ ]
mistakes and killed innocent people with
the drone strike in response to those
service members being killed serious
[ __ ] [ __ ] called war
and you're holding up a [ __ ] book and
talking about an interview get the
actual [ __ ] out of here we know who's
questioning mark millie today when matt
gatz was flapping his trap and it wasn't
matt gatz
it was mango mussolini jesus it was the
cheeto dust mobster it was grandpa poopy
pants it's a [ __ ] cult
it's a cult
and matt gatz is the general of that
cult
and it needs to stop kevin mccarthy take
him off his committee hearings and while
you're at it get the [ __ ] jim banks
out of there too this guy defending
newsmax you and epic times oh you called
them nazis
and millie's like i didn't call nazis
you call them
you just call them nazis
it's really funny the point and i i
don't have the gym clips to play but i
really wish i did because we're running
short on time but i wish i did because
there's one point there's one point
where gym bank says the epic times
is is an opposition of the chinese
communist party
well there's no there's no better enemy
for communists than nazis how do you not
know this how do they not how
how in the [ __ ]
how in the [ __ ] do they not know the
natural enemy of communist
is nazis
so the epic epic times is the enemy of
communists so i mean it's very possible
that they could be fascists
just christ
i don't know why we have to explain this
to these [ __ ]
but i'm running out of time here
so i appreciate you joining us today
and i hope i hope you had fun with the
matt getz thing and i again i wanted to
play the whole clip because i know i
know that you're probably not going to
see the whole clip anywhere else uh
what's going to happen with the right
wing is they're going to play the one
thing where matt gatz asked him the one
question that trump wanted him to ask
him the one question that the right wing
the fascist the nazis the trumpism fed
to matt gatz to ask mark milley because
they knew they could count on matt gatz
asking an unserious question to a
serious person in a serious [ __ ]
committee hearing
they knew they could count on that
[ __ ] [ __ ] to do that because he's
a [ __ ] box
he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] box and he'll
continue to be a [ __ ] box
so my suggestion is go [ __ ] vote
go [ __ ] vote and
we need to we need to talk about voting
right now you want to know what's going
to get democrats into shape in
washington talk about voting there's a
[ __ ] election coming up in virginia
and again i can't get to it i don't have
enough time but if you watch the the
debate
the only thing the only conclusion that
anyone who is against trumpism the 81
million people that portion of men are
in virginia
that voted against trumpism the only
conclusion that you can draw from that
debate is to vote for terry mcauliffe
that's it that's that's the thing that
you draw from it if you vote against
trumpism and you are in virginia you're
one of the 81 million people that
resided in virginia go vote vote vote
vote vote for terry mcauliffe
that's what you have to do that's what
we have to continue to do we have to
talk about voting right now we can't
wait until next next fall to talk about
voting we have to talk about voting
right now
right now and voting for anyone who is
anti-fascist anti-trumpism just like
they did in the california recall and
piled up those votes out there so let's
keep talking about it let's keep talking
about it on twitch stream so join me
there i do those maybe we'll start
scheduling those
to where you guys know a schedule of
when i'm going to be on twitch to stream
that's a lot more casual than here on
the podcast the podcast is more of a
live radio type show but but the twitch
is a little different we go on there and
we we surf through twitter and we find
all the topics the trending topics and
we talk about all those things so join
me there join me next week three o'clock
central four o'clock eastern same time
same place youtube twitter twitch for
the podcast you can go download the
podcast on apple
spotify all those directories have the
the podcast join us next week i think
we're gonna have a special guest episode
also next week on friday
uh three o'clock central four o'clock
eastern again we'll stream that on
youtube twitter twitch and it'll be on
all the directors as well so pay
attention to that
one last thing though before i go
[ __ ] em
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them